direction à présent les côtes d'armor au
large de perros-guirec se trouve la
réserve naturelle des sept îles et ses
célèbres fous de bassan
une réserve qui est l'objet de tensions
entre l'état et la commune de perros
guirec les habitants ne veulent pas que
le domaine maritime entourant la réserve
fasse partie du secteur protégé un
paradoxe que nous explique sébastien
legay et christian leroux discrètement
dans l' escort des goélands leroy 17 il
s'est immiscé le fou de bassan semble
accueillir ces jeunes visiteurs pour les
conduire vers son domaine l'île
mystérieuse d'eurosic où logent 17000
coupe une tache blanche et à trop large
de perros-guirec
si vous avez vu aussi ceux qui portent
des algues ouais si les piaillements de
ses enfants breton couvre parfois ceux
de leurs hôtes
c'est qu'il n'avait jamais vu un
macareux moine ni même un fou de bassan
laissait-il réserve naturelle depuis
1912 surface 280 ha du moins à marée
basse
aujourd'hui l'état et la ligue de
protection des oiseaux gestionnaire
veulent étendre la réserve à la mer
argument les oiseaux et les phoques vive
tôt tant en mer que sur terre
la réserve doit rester ouverte aux
usages locaux et qu'ils soient amateurs
ou professionnels et nous comptons bien
justement sur l'adhésion de la
population et notamment les pêcheurs
professionnels pour adhérer à ce projet
qui ne prévoit aucune aucune contrainte
aucune contrainte
les habitants méfiant regroupés sous la
bannière de l'association archipel libre
n'y crois pas ils redoutent qu'à
l'avenir on leur interdisent la pêche et
la navigation
surtout ils sont vexés que l'état ait
voulu décider sans les consulter
qu'on protège quand tu auras besoin de
protéger -sous jamais ya un problème
d'accord mais qu'on laisse un peu les
populations des habitants de leur
patrimoine
g demandait aux gens forte de mille huit
cents adhérents l'association
participent désormais aux négociations
pour étouffer dans l'oeuf dit elle
les menaces éventuelles dans le rôle
délicat du conciliateur le sous préfet
de lannion
il enchaîne les réunions avec les
multiples acteurs du dossier
nous avons un milieu qui est à la fois
lié au tempérament ni au tempérament
bourton qui est très réactif et très
très dynamique
une vie qui réactif aussi sur des sujets
comme ça à perros-guirec tout le monde
dit aimer les sept îles et c'est
étonnant locataires le problème n'est
pas là si la réserve englobe la mer qui
sépare cet éden de la côte
les habitants ont peur à tort ou à
raison de 100 sentir dépossédés